[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome back to Moon signs
this podcast is about breaking our
boundaries of knowledge and getting
wiser every day
in this episode we will be discussing
about the impact English language has
made around the globe in the recent few
years
so how did English Captivate the world
every day is a new experience and
everyday people change alongside all
these changes English had its own growth
it is the most common language in the
world the impact it has in the society
is huge English is used in Global
Communication and international dialogue
both in personal and official situations
it allows us to form friendships Beyond
borders
these days knowledge of English is a
required skill in many high performing
companies individuals can look for jobs
across many different countries it has
also impacted the business World
accelerating the performance of
companies and improves overall
employability for those with knowledge
of this language
another important change is the way
English is transforming cultures this
trend is especially strong among younger
Generations due to English being the
most common language on the Internet
besides the positive impact it has its
negative effects as well as more
cultures are influenced by Western
Society language Native and diverse
cultural heritage may be damaged
the importance of English is pretty high
especially in education learning a new
language can help broaden students Minds
while also help them develop emotional
skills as we already mentioned it
provides job opportunities and help
people communicate through the internet
across the globe many international
schools offer English classes this
allows to train International
professionals and future skilled experts
which are not limited by their native
country borders English has a huge
impact on globalization as it allows all
of us to speak in one common language
this is something unique that has never
been possible before in history
people are now roaming freely across
countries English being Global language
allows them to look for help on airports
or tourist information points
furthermore it helps communities offer
better tourism experience for visitors
it can be considered as a symbiote which
brings great benefits to both local
community and tourists internet is
surely what enabled our Global
interconnected modern lifestyle
English had a huge impact on internet
but internet may have even bigger impact
on English possibly due to the fact that
more than 50 percent of Internet content
represents this language so as we can
see the importance of English in our
daily lives is important indeed the
world is functioning in different ways
than it used to who would have thought
about this we came at the end of our
podcast and I wish you found each part
of it interesting remember
the true purpose of education is to make
Minds not careers
[Music]
foreign